it's one of the most anticipated
activities of the year harvesting
mangoes the the sherry variety is native
to uttar pradesh in northern india
janet faridi's family has owned this
orchard for centuries he says a
scorching hot summer has destroyed at
least 30 percent of his crop
we witnessed unprecedented heat this
time the weather destroyed our crop at
all stages from flowering to ripening
even though we gave a lot of water we
didn't get the output we usually get
rainfall has also been low
south asia is the world's largest
producer of mangoes but the march peak
growing season was the hottest in a
century and average temperatures in
april were much higher than normal
traders say production is down by nearly
70 percent in india and by nearly half
in pakistan this is just one of the 1500
varieties of mangoes found across india
the summer favorite is locally called
the king of fruits and holds immense
cultural value the roles are globally
renowned but the pandemic has disrupted
the multi-million dollar trade and this
year exports are expected to decline
even further
less produce has pushed up prices and
sellers say inflation has also impacted
their incomes
we are able to sell but the business is
not as profitable even the farmers say
they are not making as much money this
year the season is about to end in about
20 days we have stock but the prices are
much higher
experts say rapid urbanization in the
region has also degraded orchards and
climate change is making them even more
vulnerable when we talk about solutions
we are actually talking about
adaptability
and in pakistan unfortunately we do not
have a national adaptation plan which
has to be in place for us
to kind of introduce climate smart
agriculture techniques so that we can
actually
cope up with the changing environment
this also calls for capacity building of
local farmers so that they can adapt to
the changing environment
global warming is expected to make
extreme weather events more common and
intense and junaid faridi says he can
only hope the government will do more to
help farmers like him pav nimittal
al-jazeera new delhi